well i know that you're conscious
because i can interact directly with you
but am i
well unless you're a figment in my
imagination of course nor or i'm a robot
that's able to generate the illusion uh
yes the illusion of consciousness
effectively enough to facilitate a good
conversation because we humans do want
to pretend that we're talking to other
conscious beings that's how we respect
them if it's not conscious we don't
respect them we're not good at talking
to robots that's true of course we
generalize from our own inner sense
which is the kind of thing descartes
said
from the beginning and we generalize
from that but i do think that
consciousness must be
something whatever it is that occurs as
a result of some particular
organizational structure of
material elements
does materialism mean that it's all
within
within the reach of science
my sense would be that
especially as
uh neuroscience
progresses more and more and at caltech
we just built a whole neuroscience
arena and so on and as
more knowledge is gained about the ways
in which
animals
when they behave what patterns show up
at various parts of the brain and
nervous system and perhaps extending it
to humans eventually as well
we'll get more of a handle
on
what brain activity is associated
with uh experiences
that
we have as humans can we move from the
brain activity to the experiences
in terms of our person no you can't
perception is perception
that's the hypothesis once again
maybe maybe the
maybe consciousness is just one of the
laws of physics that's yet to be
discovered
maybe it permeates all matter
maybe it's
maybe it's as simple as trying to plug
it in and um
plug into
the ability to generate and control that
kind of law of physics that would crack
open where we would understand that the
water that the bottled water is in fact
conscious just much less conscious than
us humans and then we would be able to
generate uh beings that are more
conscious
well that'll be unfortunate i'd have to
stop drinking the water after that sorry
every time you take it take a sip
there's a little bit of a
suffering going on right
you